[Music]
hey everybody Neil degrass Tyson here
I've got with me Brian Green theoretical
physicist Columbia University and the
two of us we're just going to Riff on
Oppenheimer the man and especially
Oppenheimer the
movie Just for your eavesdropping on our
conversation so Brian I I trust you've
seen the film I have you know
I Barbie heered by the way I don't want
oh you did I did not do
that why
not couldn't bear it sorry but I should
see it should yeah that's that's seeing
both movies on the same day it's to
Barbie yeah yeah know I guess that that
opportunity then has
passed and it is true and I can like go
back so um we've I met Christopher Nolan
previously we've had him as a guest on
Star talk after one of his sort of time
warping sort of movies that he had
produced and a very smart guy very um
clever with a lot of attention to detail
and my sense of the film was that it
captured so much of what he cares about
uh he cares about science he cares about
culture he cares about entertainment he
cares about all of this and every little
physics tid bitty fact that I knew from
that era he managed to capture not with
an entire off-ramp just to just to put
in a fact that you know should be there
he managed to fully Stitch it and weave
it so that I felt like I was sitting on
oppenheimer's shoulder watching all of
this unfold before me yeah I definitely
had a similar feeling about it I mean
there were certainly moments when and
there were things on screen that I
suspect most people wouldn't take much
note of such as the Einstein and girdle
who would famously go for walks together
I mean there were the wonderful moments
when I was just sitting there feeling
like you know or or find them playing
The Bongo yes yes because Fineman is not
ided in the movie he's the person
playing fan is credited at the end but
the word fan doesn't come out of
anybody's mouth and so you have to pay
attention in that party scene he's
playing the Bongos and it was fean in
the car because in one of his Memoirs
watch in one of his Memoirs he described
the fact that he knew that ordinary
glass is a very significant UV absorber
and so while they're slathering each
other with what is it zinc oxide for to
for the explosion he's in the car and he
says no I don't need that I've got the
windshield it's a heavy absorber of UV
and then they have a that was F in the
car and and then yeah yeah and then
someone else says well but what will
protect you from the
windshield which
I'm so that was a good rebuttal so were
two V so somebody had to know that
little tidbit about fem men and then put
it in seamlessly and and and that's not
even someone who's where they make a big
deal of of for his presence that's what
was beautiful about it it wasn't like
hitting you over the head with it like
here's this obscure fact that only we
you in on the Bongos right right no
no yeah you know the only moment that
gave me pause and I don't know if you
had the similar feeling or not I mean
you and I both spend time giving people
a sense of The Wonder of the cosmos and
things of that but the first handful of
minutes of the film which kind of tried
to go into the mind of a physicist
swirling galaxies and these equations
what it just would have felt like that
felt a little much to me I don't know if
it hit you that way at all yeah so I
think without
that Oppenheimer is
really just a
manager we don't see him manifest much
physics
knowledge throughout he's managing the
the expertise of others so that that
basically established his street cred
especially since his most cited paper is
not about normal physics it's about the
universe and black holes right which
really didn't have much to do with this
film sorry didn't have much to do with
his leadership in this
role so I thought I gave I I thought
that was okay I otherwise you won't get
to do that in elsewhere where yeah yeah
I mean ultimately it all worked but for
the first few minutes I was wondering
where this was going
but yeah I I I I love the way that the
historical facts were blended with I
guess things that were well motivated
but you know opad harmer's own personal
perspective on what was happening versus
the things that are in the public record
yeah in fact it was definitely his POV
no doubt about it so what I liked about
it was all of the ank people had about
the bomb in a military setting against
the Germans but then against the the the
Japanese and the Jewish science in in in
Germany uh they you know they toss bones
to each of these without actually taking
off ramps because the offramp would be
well we're a historical documentary we
have to fully cover it no you don't it's
just his point of view so but they got
it all in there for example they talked
about
well how special is this bomb we just
firebomb Tokyo and killed 100,000 people
with conventional incendiary bombs and
this your estimates are not even that
high so how could you carry some guilt
with this when we've already uh
committed that level of violence against
uh uh um
non-combatant uh civilians so that came
up and then there was the well what is
this with Germany Hitler and the Jews
how is that going to play out and my
favorite line there which I think
encapsulates a lot of historical
Dimension where they say uh Heisenberg
might know this because will we get it
Heisenberg is brilliant will we get it
before heisen no because he's Jewish and
Hitler doesn't give Jews access to the
labs it relegates them to pencil and
pads and so this was so that was a
fascinating indictment of Nazi
racism basically and how that very fact
uh probably contributed to their uh
however slow they were on the
development of the bomb on Monday April
8th the great North American Eclipse
will pass over the United States with
only 05% of the world's population
falling within its path of totality yep
that's just 05% of the world that'll be
able to witness this reverential
experience in its entirety and guess
what our friends in Little Rock Arkansas
are smack dab in the middle of it if
you're looking for one of the best
places to view this year's eclipse look
no further than Little Rock they still
have hotels available to fit every
budget witness complete and total
darkness on April 8th and take part in
Little Rock special events and
celebrations leading up to the big day
starting on April 6 from Outdoor
Adventures like hiking biking and
paddling to educational activities like
visiting the Clinton Presidential
library or the Museum of Discovery
little rocks got a little something for
everyone to book your visit and witness
this Monumental event in person head
over to little rock.com
Eclipse that's little rock.com
Eclipse paid for with a combination of
State funds and private heart of
Arkansas Association
funds now the other thing though I
wonder your thought on this I was very
impr impressed with how the Carnage was
treated you know I thought it was a very
traumatic moment no spoiler here you
know when the sound went off and you had
this moment before the actual explosion
and then you don't really see the
Carnage in any gory explicit way but
then I began to think about that and I
watched the day after Trinity I think
that's the name of the documentary and I
began to think you know for so many
young people this may be their only
direct con action to the events that
happened at the end of World War
II maybe there needed to be more of the
shocking visuals in order that the
generation really really un they
described them they did describe them
they said person with a striped shirt
where the dark stripes were it burned
their skin and where the light Stripes
were it didn't there were other people
where their Shadows were burned into the
the the the exterior of their Shadow was
burned into pavement I wonder if that's
not though you know especially you know
if it's the only the only yeah okay
yeah yeah so because
War sometimes you have to see it up
close to know that you should never do
it and this is a certain kind of
violence to humanity that is of a scale
and of A Sort that is so
spectacularly agonizing and and awful
and to not fully feel that even
momentarily maybe maybe a bit of a law
what about the scene where he we inside
his head and he's about to talk about
the success of the bomb to the assembled
people and he yeah and he
sees flashes and people's skin burning
off yeah that's in his head it's not the
documentary of what happened in Nagasaki
and Hiroshima but it was also very
relatively brief it was brief yes so so
yes I mean it's a difficult decision to
make because as a film I thought it
worked
sply as a work of art about this
incredibly destructive moment and this
incredibly destructive period but as a
again it's not a documentary but it may
be treat as a documentary yeah as off
yeah our movies are sources of
historical know for sure you the a few
other things that I noticed that he did
was we used to say Hiroshima and then
later people started saying Hiroshima in
the movie It's said both
way in two different cases it's and I it
has to be on purpose just so he's got
both bases covered he's got both covered
um yeah also generally when I see a
movie a second time I hear the
soundtrack more because I'm not
distracted by having to pay attention to
the plot in Oppenheimer I already knew
what was happening so I I was able to
hear the sound track and the moments
leading up to the bomb test with the
button there is cous orchestral music
and the editing pace is Fast and the
music is getting louder and louder and
more
cinus and you you're not going to know
that because you're anticipating
what's about to happen and if you're not
aware of the music which good music in a
movie you're not aware of it it's just
managing your emotions when they hit the
button and you see the
explosion it is the silence is deafening
because they take away the music and of
course there's the sound Delay from the
explosion to where they are so he
doubles up on this on the silence right
yeah that was beautiful that was really
beautiful and so so they they were what
one two miles away uh sound will go a
mile every six seconds so the blast wave
moving at the speed of sound I think
that calculation looked right to me yeah
right sort of 8 10 seconds or whatever
it was yeah yeah well there were a few
miles yeah that's right but between one
and two miles away would would do that
and uh they trusted their calculations
why did they give so much weight to the
risk of igniting the atmosphere seems to
me that probability would have been so
low to be astronomically low but it
makes a really good hemline oh my gosh
we could have ended the world and and
it's astronomically low probability for
for ending the world does Dem man a
certain degree of a
10 okay yeah well I didn't mean to I
thank you I
agree yeah it's a real it was a real
worry and people had to sit down and and
do the cockfish and look we had the same
thing the Large Hadron Collider people
worry that you turn on the accelerator
create a little black hole that would
swallow up Switzerland and then the did
you video of of a of a um security
camera in the parking lot of the large
hron collider and there's a countdown
clock then went to zero and then every
of it was sad and hilarious at the same
time then it but the serious point is
it's a real concern and You' got to sit
down and do the calculation and
colleagues of mine did the calculation
and showed that it wasn't something that
we should worry about unlikely yes
spectacularly unlikely that you could
put it to the side but this is what we
should always do you know because you
know ending the world's kind of a big
deal you know so but what do reaction I
mean when I think of the uh you're
splitting uranium 235 it sends out to
neutrons hits other nearby uranium atoms
why why would that ignite the atmosphere
what would happen what nuclear process
in the in the oxygen nitrogen atmosphere
were they thinking would happen yeah
it's a good question I don't know the
details of the mechanism that was most
concerning to the SES of the time but
you were
creating temperatures and densities of
energy that we had never created before
on Earth and so you got to ask yourself
is there any collateral process that
this may spark and the answer is in
principle yes in practice no and that's
what you need to do to ensure that these
things are safe do you know that some of
the primary work on the process that you
just described where you 235 splits and
neutrons are sent out happened in the
building where I'm sitting right now
you at Columbia University had Leo card
who is one of the first people in fact
The Story Goes I believe that he was
crossing the street in 1933 in London
just after the discovery of the neutron
by James Chadwick in 1932 and then it
hit him and it hit him in fact in Cosmos
we went to that very same street corner
oh you did is that yes we did and I
walked up to the street corner and I had
no such aipan
personally that Chon istically in time
and place but we did go to that moment
rightly but then he came card came to
Columbia he was working here in this
building fery was in this building
they're on different floors each trying
to determine whether you would generate
multiple neutrons from these
dissociations because if you could get
multiple neutrons they then could have
the cascading effect yeah yeah the Chain
Reaction that's what chain reaction gain
currency is a term back then so are you
in pupin Hall are you in pupin Hall I'm
right now yeah in pupin Hall that's
where I got my PhD from to Wars uh with
the astronomers on the top floors by the
way yeah but it was then that that
salard and vigner when they realized
this is a real possibility they get in a
car and they drive to Long Island I
think it's 1939 to convince Einstein to
write the letter that they talk about an
Oppenheimer yes when Einstein writes to
Roosevelt saying hey we got to get a
move on there's a real potential for
possible at all yeah I I also heard that
uh Oppenheimer did not have a one-on-one
meeting with Einstein but they had
corresponded and so what they did was
use because we knew Einstein is always
wandering and alone or with in
conversation one-on-one they created a
conversation that would have been
plausible uh expression of what their
correspondence was so I didn't have a
problem that I don't know I'd heard I'd
heard that so but I I was okay with that
just because yeah why not you get three
for one there you get you get uh
Oppenheimer in conversation with with uh
Albert Einstein and the institute for
advanced study yeah the ingredients are
all
right in a creative way one thing I
tweeted this uh again I'll give I'll
give him a hall pass uh Christopher
Nolan so July 16th is the test that's
summertime and at the latitude on Earth
where this occurred at 5:30 in the
morning we are well into morning
Twilight right it was dark it would not
have been pitch dark but if you want a
spectacular explosion against a dark sky
I'd give him the dark sky I've I've been
there I've been to where you probably
have too where they did the test yes
yeah because I in a overa program they
had me take a a guer counter and
actually you know and yeah you get some
click click click I mean there's still
some residual impact wrong wait a minute
wait wait
so so so now you have the evidence of
your current
sterility like you haven't had a kid in
a few years that's what the problem
is um so I thought the M it was two
movies there was the making of the bomb
and then the trial and uh it's quite a
challenge to keep that going you know
after you have you know the largest
explosion Earth had ever seen um yeah I
think the the wisdom that Einstein was
revealed that he shared with him at the
end was uh in the end whatever they're
doing to now in the end they're going to
have to thank you and basically that's
that's that's where the movie went but
is interesting question I mean I don't
really face it directly in my own work
but my kids asked mate would you have
gone and worked on the Manhattan Project
if you were around at the time and you
know it's a tough question but I suspect
I would have gotten caught up in the
same kind of fervor because when you see
what was happening at Los Alamos and the
movie does a really good job of this you
realize that these scientists are
getting they're caught up in this ocean
of excitement to do something that no
one has ever done new science new
science yit money to back it right yeah
and there's a I don't know if you've
seen this but Freeman Dyson there's a
quote of his it's in this documentary
DEA Trinity he says something like the
feeling of power so that sense of you
are grabbing hold of the universe and
you now are using its most powerful
forces to shape reality it's hard not to
get caught up in that right you would
you have gone so it's you know it's
hindsight is very have much more
confidence and hindsight than at the
time so I'm I'm a little conflicted for
the following reason um my father was in
the service okay at the time and the
Army was segregated it was a segregated
Army it wasn't become desegregated until
later and so
who who am I really defending right what
is who's my enemy yeah you know this is
this was a very real thing mixed with
the lynchings in the South and the and
so
maybe I would have
joined out of because I I don't want I
didn't want Hitler to take over because
we can no matter what's going on here we
all agree Hitler was bad but once we
learned that Hitler was was about to be
defeated to turn it on Japan I don't
know if if I were to if I had an exit
point it would have been there yeah
yeah because you know Leo salard one of
the things that he was advocating and
you know it's sort of a travesty that we
didn't do it explode the first bomb in
an uninhabited Place demonstrate the
power of this Atomic weapon and that
should be enough to cause any enemy
combatant to say okay we give up don't
drop that thing on us and yet that's not
what we did right well plus we only had
two of them right yeah I mean to get
uranium
235 that's not the natural state of
uranium in the ground right I mean so
you have to centrifuge it and I keep
thinking in a centrifuge they do they
just they liquefy the uranium they have
to have some details yeah yeah yeah and
so uh any anything else about the film
that struck you well um I I I thought
they caught
well the achievement which is sort of
odd to say because so many people died
because of the achievement but think
about this abstract idea that these
little things called atoms have neutrons
that might spit out a few that would
break apart other atoms I mean it's such
an abstract idea the idea of harnessing
that within a decade to actually do
something to me is an
unfathomable scientific achievement let
me put the Hara to the side and I
thought they they captured that really
well so in my world
okay uh you may not know this but the uh
uranium the element was discovered
shortly after planet Uranus was named
okay so they wanted to sort of you know
they knew the elements should have a
deeper more cosmically inspired Gman
clure than other so they so uranium is
named after the planet Uranus okay don't
tell me plutonium is getting there I'm
you just back I and then then we
discovered planet Neptune and shortly
after element number 93 was discovered
that was named
neptunium in
1930 the object forly known as a planet
Pluto was discovered and in 1940 element
94 was discovered and in in Tradition
and in that sequence it was named after
Pluto plutonium my point is we discover
plutonium in 19 40 and it is weaponized
and tested 5 years later yeah within 5
years this is an
extraordinary machine that has been put
into place yes and we knew uranium was
visible so we didn't have to test that
bomb yeah the plutonium was a new
element so many people don't know that
the bomb that was tested was a plutonium
bomb not a uranium bomb yeah yeah yeah
but even you know the file nature of
uranium was only established in the mid
to late 30s okay well it's eternity
given the you're fighting a whole war
with battleships yeah but it's it's
again look I mean you as a theorist who
just plays with equations I stand in awe
of anybody can actually do something and
the fact that these theorists came
together with the experimenters under
the rubric of the organization that
Oppenheimer put into place The
Audacity Of The Goal yeah and the fact
that he was able to manage it and bring
it to a successful and horrific
conclusion it's just to me but but do
you think do you
think a half a dozen people could have
done that I mean consider that it's it's
a juggernaut right we are purifying the
uranium we have Hanford up in in
Washington and we have all these sites
separating the the bits and pieces and
they're all coming together kind of pay
or play with or without Oppenheimer
we're making a bomb do I don't know how
singular Oppenheimer was to that project
he's made singular courts in the film
and yeah I mean it feels singular to me
because the organization that's required
to bring together the theory and the
experiment and the engineering and the
technology it just sort of a mind
blowingly difficult challenge to to to
bring okay so you needed you needed
someone with high managerial skills and
people skills yeah and I think you need
someone who understands the science yeah
because worst thing in the world is when
you have non scientists who don't
appreciate the need for certain things I
mean the way while Alamos was set up
aimer knew how scientists work yeah yeah
have they they they come together and
without that culture I don't think this
would ever have have come to be but it's
interesting to note I believe that alen
heimer's initial plan was something like
I don't know 20 or 30
people if it wasn't like however many
they had I don't know what the final
number was it was over a thousand you
know I I mean that was not the original
plan but that was what it was requiring
to get to the F yeah another thing I
liked which was almost uh it was so uh I
was tickled by it each time it happened
I got tickled uh in all those meetings
that they're having are all these other
scientists who are very famous
scientists of the era who have formulas
named after them who have accelerators
named after them and it was just um uh
like uh was that EO Lawrence who was the
guy working Lawrence from from Lawrence
Livermore yeah yeah Lawrence Livermore
La buing his first cyclotron or whatever
it was yeah yeah and Berkeley um yeah
it's amazing it's also amazing to me
that Oppenheimer got them to go and that
to me I mean we the film shows it him
talking and you know getting
the but wow I mean how do you get that
many people to get up and leave their
home move into the middle of nowhere
what persuasive powers that must have
required you know to get people to do
that it's just again an amazing feat and
what do you make of their persistent
discussion about the difference between
vision and fusion I didn't remember that
to be a big issue at the time we all
knew Fusion would be in whole other
another another right because you're
you're fusing hydrogen into healing
completely
different Nuclear Physics from fision
but they seem to make a big deal of it
and I don't remember that being an issue
you know I don't know historically
speaking but I gather from plot line the
reason was because oppenheimer's less
than enthusiastic position they need
they needed to set that up need to set
that up because Edward Teller who then
testifies later on in the committee that
ultimately revokes this op arm security
clearance and they shook each other's
hands you saw that yeah they they did
but that was respect no but that was I
mean I but where did yeah I I agree I
totally agree with all that but part of
the was white didn't you was
sh right but you know but teller was
gungho on the hyrogen bomb and
Oppenheimer was less so because he
thought he would divert resources from
the atomic Weaponry which he actually
was quite a fan of because he viewed
this as a means of now having some
mutually assured destruction that might
cause peace to Prevail and the hydrogen
bomb was not where he wanted the
resources to go but I yes in order to
set that up they wanted us as an
audience to know that there's a
difference between the fion bombs that
Oppenheimer developed and the fusion
right it's not just another nuke right
not just another nuke yeah right right
right and because when they shook hands
I thought
Oppenheimer
respected teller's
reasoning yeah about he would revoke it
and I and I
thought it takes two scientists to do
that right yeah I mean most break out in
fisticuffs but if it's deeply reasoned
then the argument is sound it's not a
matter of what your preference is it's
this is the argument and I got to go
with the argument yeah and I think
there's also a deep level of respect
that underlies these relationships
because this is rarified physics
knowledge I mean to be able to do
Quantum calculations and to be able to
really
understand the details of how these
devices work not many people ever get to
that level right and sort of It's a
small club and entry into that club is
all coming from up here and I think that
yields as basic level of respect even if
you differ on on critical issues here's
a question I had for you I had not
appreciated until I saw the film how
shortly after the development of quantum
mechanics people had to make these
quantum mechanical calculations right
now we are on the in the Centennial
decade of the discovery of quantum
mechan the major tenets of quantum
mechanics were the 1920s and there you
have the 30s and right into the four 15
years later they're manipulating all the
quantum equations to make
calculations how could you just put me
in that moment was quantum physics so
thoroughly believed and trusted
that people just walked flat-footed into
this and and and made the bomb with it I
mean is that
how or were there people saying I it was
Ein Einstein said God does not play dice
with the universe this was his
indictment of quantum physics yeah but
but it's a but I think that's a good
starting point for discussing it because
Einstein also said that he believed that
quantum mechanics was a correct Theory
but something told him that there was a
deeper description yet to be found okay
so not that it was wrong not that it was
wrong yeah and again you know Einstein
as you know his Nobel Prize was for the
photo El electric effect which was one
of the
first achievements of a Quantum
perspective yeah and and and so so ever
since 1926 27 the basic equations are
written down Schrodinger's equations or
Heisenberg's Matrix mechanics
formulation they're equivalent and so
things have been in place for a decade
and Triumph over Triumph in these
quantum equations yeah LED people to a
great confidence that yeah maybe
Einstein's right maybe there's a deeper
understanding but we don't need we don't
need that we don't need just shut up and
calculate yes and then you know not all
the equations that are underlying the
development the bomber Quantum
calculations you know there's a whole
engineering side of thing yeah I thought
they they I don't think they gave enough
credit to the engineers in this yeah in
the film somebody's got to build it and
the physicist is not building it the
theoretical physicist doesn't know which
end is up yeah that's what leaves me in
awe I mean I understand how that those
bomb designs were you know little boy
fatmano is all all conceptually clear to
me yes but if you even today in 2023
gave me a big laboratory and told me to
build one of these
things
I I would do with a hammer and a
screwdriver and you would know what you
know i' have i' have to hire a whole
group and I again be just looking at
them from a distance
I you
know arms crossed okay I'll do like EXA
you know yeah I always have dreamed that
one day I should take an experimental
course even given by my colleagues here
at Columbia so I'd really get my hands
dirty when some Street crack yeah
exactly you know um but like I said when
I was being tickled by all the names all
those names everybody has a Nobel Prize
for some uh and they're just casual
names bandied about in the salon and in
the Coffee Lounge and everywhere else
yeah yeah one last thing I thought they
made an interesting distinction about
his brand of
Communism right and it was a you know
they gave a lot of attention to this
topic with his brother and his wife and
his friends and his donations of money
to causes and specifically the movie
makes no mention of McCarthy in in the
Senate okay there's a m where we see him
right you might see him but we never at
any time are told McCarthy needs to
right to interrogate you and I think
it's because this is my reading onto
this that that he was above McCarthy pay
grade okay McCarthy is digging out movie
stars and people you know and here's
someone who is you know winning wars for
us right and so I so my sense was you
don't want him mix yes there was a there
was a Red Scare yes but the McCarthy
variant of that was very pedestrian
relative to what was going on at his
level in the government that's how I
that's how I viewed that but also you
know what kind of are you Carl Marx
communist or do you just want the worker
to have dignity you know there the the
ways to slice this totally and my sense
was when they said do you agree I forgot
the exact scripting here but he said
yeah there's some things they do that I
resonate with not everything yeah right
and if you try to always are you with
this or you're against us yeah then you
get McCarthyism but if you if you trust
that not all answers are binary in this
way then you're allowed to be nuanced
and think of Oppenheimer not as some
traitor but as as a patriot who's who
has his own conscience yeah no totally I
mean I I you mentioned your dad before I
grew up yeah my dad was very much in the
spirit of Oppenheimer Vis his views on
communism you know and that was a tough
position to was he part of just that
huge community of of the the uh Jews who
were totally into the Communist CA
absolutely absolutely you know he was
one step away on you know from the
rosenbergs you know and and he was very
close friends with the people who
ultimately adopted the the Rosenberg
kids so it was a very it was a very
difficult time to hold a nuanced view
but you're absolutely right you know the
world is not made up of black white
answers to most of these very
fundamental questions it's somewhere in
the gray place in between just a Qui
side to that uh the Civil Rights
Movement as it manifested in the
1960s was brilliantly conceived because
uh remember a big part of that movement
was once again dignity and first voting
rights and and housing rights but also
uh the Dignity of uh honest pay for a
day's work to get you out of poverty
yeah that is cerine to the communist
movement and what they said was we can't
have Communists leading this movement at
a time when we're fighting Communists in
the world so and Communists are Godless
right because in the 50s we put God on
the money and God on the back wall of
the Senate and God in the in the Pledge
of Allegiance right God didn't used to
be there before the 1950s originally to
one nation under God indivisible that
totally breaks up that sentence it was
one nation indivisible with libert that
was the original wording I did I did not
know that complete Serv One Nation
indivisible they FW in under God to
demonstrate that we are God-fearing and
Communists have no God all right point
is if you get Martin Luther King a
preacher to lead a civil rights movement
he can speak to the rights of the
workers without anybody thinking he's
communist because he Praises Jesus right
right so whatever communism the brand
was at the time
it enabled you to still talk about
workers rights without being um a
shuttled way into the Communist ghetto
which is what that was yeah no I and I
thought they handled that that well yeah
so two thumbs up for our movie review is
it I I give it two thumbs up yeah and so
next we'll talk about
Barbie we C you back absolutely all
right Brian nice chatting with you talk
to you Christopher Nolan uh I think it's
it's a contender for multiple Academy
Awards
including a doubt all right this has
been a start talk conversation with my
friend and colleague theoretical
physicist Brian Green all about
Oppenheimer and the bom until next time
keep looking
up